[Music]
these images of an Eritrean man being
beaten by an Israeli mob as he lay dying
have shocked many security guards say
they shot half tombs are who because
they thought he was an accomplice to a
Palestinian who just shot and killed as
a soldier as are who lay bleeding on the
floor of the bus station the crowd
dumping bench on him and kicked him in
the head Israeli police say they're
investigating circles killing but this
is just another graphic episode in a
disturbing trend in response to knife
attacks by Palestinians acts of mob
violence have become common there's the
angry crowd that successfully demanded
police shooting kill 19 year old Fatih a
loon or the crowd that pinned down and
beat a woman when she argued with a taxi
driver Israeli human rights group
B'Tselem said such incidents raised
concern that the chosen response to such
persons is the harshest possible with
lethal or the very least unnecessary
consequences but what's pushing people
to act like this in the streets and this
does come out of real genuine legitimate
fear about it it's gone to this point of
legitimizing very extreme mob violence
after czar Holmes death Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu said nobody
may take the law into their own hands
but other Israeli politicians seem to be
encouraging citizens to do just that
this is a good way to fight people that
use knives the mayor of Jerusalem has
called in more Israelis to carry guns
and the city's gun stores have seen an
uptick in business the commander of the
Jerusalem Police said that anyone who
stabs Jews or hurts innocent people is
due to be killed and Jerry Rapide who
leads a centrist yesh a tea party said
you have to shoot to kill anyone who
pulls out a knife or screwdriver the
hysteria has even led to so-called
accidental attacks Jews mistakingly
attacking other Jews or attacks on
random Palestinians all the Israeli
suspects were taken into custody alive
but many Palestinians who police allege
carried out attacks were shot dead human
rights organizations say these are extra
killings executions without a trial and
without any due process so why are
Israeli politicians encouraging them
[Music]